die miss germany wahl 2008 10 22 frauen
wollen die krone nur eine bekommt sie
hinter der bühne haben die hersteller
listen alle hände voll zu tun
entwicklern lockenstäbe 5 und sehr
langen haaren
nur eine kann sich entspannen denn ihre
frisur sitzt immer joana lamatsch die
als amtierende miss niedersachsen und
den start geht
sie ist nicht nur backstage eine kleine
sensation eine kandidatin mit rasiertem
kopf
das hat es hier noch nie gegeben eine
sonder verhandlung gab es für sie
trotzdem nicht in den
vorbereitungswochen hatte sich mit ihren
konkurrentinnen gut verstanden aber es
ist ja sind nur kurze haare es ist ja
nicht so schlimm ist und ich glaube wir
unsere persönlichkeiten haben einfach
zusammen gepasst und das sorgt das was
gezählt hat drei wochen zuvor
joana palamara chiptakt die koffer für
das abenteuer miss germany wahl ihre
radikale frisur hat sie noch gar nicht
so lange vor kurzem war sie so aus mit
dem neuen look kam auch der mut die
anmeldung zur ersten miss wahl in ihrer
heimatstadt hannover war gar nicht so
ernst gemeint aber sie gebannt
tatsächlich ich habe mir keine großen
gedanken darüber gemacht dass ich das
gewinnen möchte oder ähnliches sondern
ich habe einfach mitgemacht um es
auszuprobieren um eine erfahrung zu
sammeln und einfach nur spaß zu haben
doch der ehrgeiz war geweckt dabei
gehörte ihre leidenschaft bislang nicht
dem modeln sondern dem tanzen das studio
von orlando ihrem mentor ist ihre zweite
heimat nach der wahl zur miss
niedersachsen gab es für die junge frau
eine menge kritik wegen der frisur in
den sozialen netzwerken wurde sie
regelrecht beschimpft sie sei hässlich
sehe aus wie ein junger und krebskrank
aber das hat sie offenbar nur stärker
gemacht ich meine es ist okay dass ihr
eure meinung habt danke dafür
aber das ist nicht mein problem alles
gute sechs der 17 jährige ist heftig
aber nicht einfach durch wir sind da wir
unterstützen
also das ist deine beste freunde
mehr geht nicht aber in den wochen vor
der wahl war sie wie alle auf sich
allein gestellt auf der kanarischen
insel fuerteventura gab es für die
teilnehmerinnen fitness medientraining
und professionelle fotoshootings die
kandidatinnen wurden rundum betreut und
die 17 jahre alte schülerin aus hannover
verwandelte sich in einen extravaganten
wenige minuten vor dem finale der miss
germany wahl ihre langhaarigen
mitstreiterinnen mögen sie aber ordnen
sie ihr auch chancen ein
[Musik]
außergewöhnliche den kurzen sie sticht
sofort raus da guckt durch die mädels
durch das gericht darauf jeden fall dass
sie die definitiven finale kommen ja
auch wie sie ihre geschichte weiter gibt
also auch mit dem ganzen hintergrund
dass sie gemobbt wurde dass sich so
fiese kommentare gegen den kopf bekommen
hat und das ist einfach wahnsinn mit was
für eine persönlichkeit sie hier steht
zuhöre lange haare
also ich finde das ist alles auch nun ob
die jury das auch so sieht stellt sich
jetzt heraus aber hier scheint das
schönheitsideal bei einigen noch sehr
streng zu sein
im gesichtsbereich ist die sogenannte
goldene schnitt also die augen abstände
müssen stimmen dann der nasen kind
winkel etwa 110 grad körbchengröße b bis
zu maximal keine cellulite ja und body
mass
die schülerin aus hannover glänzt im
abendkleid auch ohne volle haarpracht
hat sich vorgenommen allem entspannt
entgegen zu sehen
nächster durchgang bademode und direkt
bei der ersten entscheidung des abends
gibt es für sie eine enttäuschung
sie schafft es nicht in die engere
auswahl und scheidet aus
am ende des abends wird eine andere die
krone tragen die neue miss germany 2018
wird die 23 jahre alte anahita rehbein
eine studentin aus stuttgart bei joanna
fließen neben der bühne jetzt doch noch
tränen aber vor rührung denn viele
gratulieren ihr trotzdem für ihren
auftritt und ihren mut aber jetzt kann
ich das machen was ich machen möchte das
machen was mir spaß macht und einfachem
ist der weg hinführt ihr weg als miss
germany 2010 dürfte für das nächste jahr
dagegen vorgezeichnet sein
und übrigens mit der crone und wäre es
ohne lange haare auch schwierig geworden
sie muss nämlich festgestellt werden